Gweneth Paltrow addresses her haters the  lifestyle guru spoke to BBC news 'as  Steven sacker at Cannes Lyon where he  asked her about topping a 2013 tabloid  survey of the most hated celebrities her  reaction quote I was like I'm the most  hated celebrity more than like Chris  Brown what did I do  for the record Brown placed twenty on  the list Gweneth ads all I can do is be  my authentic self if you know me then  you know who I am and that I have fun  and eat and I am so appreciative for my  life but I think there are things about  me that people draw conclusions  Pacho says one of those misconceptions  is that she was born with a silver spoon  but she's quick to remind us that her  dad the late Bruce Paltrow was  supportive of her acting career but  never gave her a handout also she does  indulge quote I have never had a  horrible experience with french fries  french fries are my life